hello and welcome to this session of the
microsoft research summit 2021
my name is darren edge i'm a director in
the societal resilience group at
microsoft research and today i'm talking
about technologies that we're building
to help translate real world data into
real world evidence now this notion of
real worldiness emerged in the medical
space to differentiate from the highly
controlled nature of data and evidence
emerging from randomized control trials
in the clinical space but we found broad
applicability of these ideas to societal
problems beyond healthcare especially
for those situations where it's not
possible practical or ethical to conduct
a randomized control trial
and raw data evidence play a key role in
our societal resilience research agenda
because only by translating data into
evidence can we inform the policies
decisions and actions that move us
towards
a more equitable and resilient society
so here we can see several domains where
we need to build more resilience as a
society and each case is a
large system of activities supporting
vulnerable groups of individuals in the
real world and today in this talk i'm
talking mostly about victims of human
trafficking and exploitation because
that's one of the key kind of areas for
us in the societal resilience group but
i hope to say to you that the need to
protect the privacy of vulnerable
populations and to develop policies that
support the needs of those populations
applies equally to
healthcare patients as it does to
victims of trafficking
and just as all of these activities need
collective evidence-based action all of
them also suffer from uh real-world
barriers that disrupt this process so
here's the process that we're trying to
support given a problem we collect data
that describes the problem we translate
our data into evidence and we use the
evidence to inform the actions that help
us to make progress against the problem
but in practice we meet barriers in
particular uh access to private data is
a significant barrier so if you have
data that describes vulnerable kind of
groups of individuals you very often
can't share that data because of privacy
concerns and data protection regulations
but if you don't have access to the
relevant data as a policy maker this
process is disrupted
similarly if you have access to the data
science skills that let you translate
data in general to specific points of
evidence
you won't have the evidence available to
then go ahead and act on and the process
is disrupted
and finally if the decision makers don't
have access to the means of evidence
development they might not understand
how
evidence is developed and dismiss it
they may decide that some relevant data
wasn't included or it was overlooked
and again this can disrupt the whole
end-to-end process so our approach is to
create accessible tools for evidence
development by domain experts who are
the ultimate decision makers and this
applies in two levels
the first is helping people to share
evidence of correlation within private
data sets um this is you know this kind
of exploratory analysis is where
hypotheses come from um we know uh you
know generating hypotheses is not the
same as confirming hypotheses and the
correlations are not causation but it's
a necessary start um so we need tools to
support this we also need a different
kind of tool to support this process of
developing evidence of causation from
observational data that's already been
collected
and most reward data is both private and
observational in nature so we really
need these tools and we need them
because we want to support collective
action within communities at the speed
and scale of real world problems
so let's talk now about developing
evidence of correlation from private
data
so this challenge emerged from
microsoft's participation in the tech
against trafficking uh coalition this is
a coalition of technology organizations
including uh microsoft amazon bt and
salesforce
designed to combat trafficking with
technology in particular it arose
through the inaugural accelerator
program with the counter trafficking
data collaborative or ctdc so ctdc is
initiative run by iom and it pulls data
from iom polaris liberty shared and
others to create the world's largest
database on identified victims of
trafficking
it makes a subset of that data after
it's been de-identified and anonymized
available via the ctdc website but i use
a technique called uh k anonymity to
anonymize that data and it has some some
issues so here's an illustration of what
did the line data set looks like from
ctdc
each row is a record describing an
individual victim of trafficking and
each column is an attribute that
describes either the individual or the
trafficking case
so k anonymity requires you to identify
which of these attributes are quasi
identifiers things that describe people
or individuals that may be identifying
when used in combination and so age
gender and citizenship were the ones
chosen by ctdc
k anonymity says that these
quasi-identifiers the sets of cause
identifier values must be shared by at
least k records for publication
otherwise the records are suppressed and
you can already imagine how this might
impact the utility of these data sets in
terms of preserving data set level
statistics but that's not the only
problem there's a residual privacy risk
around the topic of member inference so
this is a risk whenever any attribute
combination is rare in the data set and
linkable to a real world group whose
known size is about the same as the
account of records you can find in that
data set a membership reversal is a risk
because for victims of traffic
membership of a data set like this
implies collaboration with authorities
which can prompt retaliation against the
victim or the friends or family in ways
that pose
a safety risk so this is very clear in
the case where we find a unique
individual in the data set and we
believe that corresponds to a unique
individual in the world which a
trafficker may very well be able to
reason about if they have in-depth
knowledge about victims and how they're
trafficked in some kind of unusual
context or unusual way
but it's also a problem for small groups
of individuals so these last two records
you can see here they're all the same
but if you're a trafficker that controls
the route between philippines and saudi
arabia um and you think you have maybe
lost track of three individuals and you
see these three records in this data set
you may very well infer that those
individuals were actually the ones who
collaborated with the authorities and
this is the kind of issue we'd like to
avoid
uh and i said there's a problem with
this approach um so when ctdc used this
method on their entire database it
suppressed 40 of the records and of the
records that were left if you looked at
the attribute combinations that could
potentially be linkable 40 of those were
unique and 80
linked to small groups smaller than 10.
um so this is um you know uh quite a a
broad kind of privacy risk again that we
would like to avoid
and so you know if we think about uh
requirements for sharing data on
vulnerable populations this approach
fails on on two key points one is uh
providing privacy guarantees that cover
all attributes another is preserving
aggregate accounts for official
reporting and we see that the
k anonymity approach you say just didn't
meet those requirements
we could use uh differential privacy and
in particular a differentially private
query mechanism to query the data set
that would solve those problems but it
would introduce other problems it
wouldn't make a data set available for
analysis uh it wouldn't allow unlimited
queries um a differential priority
project protects individuals but not
groups and the privacy guarantees can be
quite hard to explain
now there's a different implementation
of differential privacy around how you
can use those guarantees to create
synthetic data that captures which of
the qualities of the original data this
is a step in the right direction but
again uh data produced in this way
doesn't protect groups it only protects
individuals and the privacy guarantees
are again quite hard to explain but we
can combine the best of the the ideas
here uh to create uh synthetic data that
has uh k anonymity guarantees across all
of its uh attribute columns all of its
attribute combinations um
and this is the foundation of our
approach uh so what we do um in our
synthetic data showcase tool which is
currently available on github is to
create synthetic synthetic data records
only from attribute combinations that
are common in the sensitive data so if
you find a unique attribute combination
in a sensitive data set you know by
construction they must describe a much
larger group of individuals in the
original sensitive data set so you can't
link that combination to any actual
person in the world which is the
previously guaranteed that you want but
if i give you some synthetic data you
may very reasonably ask well how well
does this data set describe this
particular group of victims that i care
about and so to help answer that
question we also generate aggregate data
precomputed for more short combinations
of attributes in the sensitive data for
interactive comparison and we enabled
that uh within the context of a data
dashboard built in power bi
uh so our partners iom have used this to
create uh the first ctdc global human
trafficking synthetic data set that was
released in september this year
if you scroll down you can find the the
dashboard that allows interactive
exploration of this data set and so i'll
uh walk through uh the data now
on the left you can see in light green
estimated counts from the synthetic data
and over on the right you can see in the
the dark green actual counts
pre-computed from the sensitive data uh
and rounded for release for privacy
reasons um but you can see again by
design at the outset the synthetic data
perfectly captures the counts of all
attributes in the sensitive data and
this is really useful compared to
okay anonymity we're not losing uh large
chunks of data we're retaining those
data set level statistics and you can
see there are many many attributes in
this data set and we don't know in
advance which may be of interest to any
particular user so it's important that
we capture and communicate all of them
now
the whole idea of the dashboard is that
you can drill down into your data to
learn about different groups of
individuals in the real world and so
here i've selected the year 2019 for the
year registration of these victims and
again i can see
how the counts
from the uh the actual sensitive data
compare to the synthetic data and we can
see that those distributions pretty much
maintain a close degree of similarity
even as i drill down into the data set
so here i'm looking at uh female victims
of sexual exploitation in the usa um
again uh those counts are captured quite
well uh i do notice here um there are
several uh attributes where the
estimated count of victims is one that
means it's a unique combination in the
synthetic data set but you can see that
the the actual account in each case is
30. so um it's not a privacy risk and
that's our privacy guarantee uh in
action
so as we keep adding attributes to our
query as we keep drilling down as we
keep making selections at some point we
run out of pre-computer combinations
but that's fine because we're typically
only looking at quite small groups by
that stage and hopefully we've built the
user's confidence in the data set by
showing accurate results at higher
levels
so let's now look at you know a small
data subset so for
exploitation in the usa we can notice
that there's around 100 or so victims
from the federated states of micronesia
and you can see on the right that the
tool has captured that population uh
quite
accurately so we also have data on all
forms of labor and sexual exploitation
we can use this to look for potential
crossovers between those forms of
exploitation so for example here i'm
looking at
a type of labor hospitality i'm seeing
some crossover with uh prostitution and
i'm saying this is a particular issue
for citizens of cuba uh who are being
exploited in the united states uh mostly
in 2019.
so again this is not conclusive evidence
of a
you know a problem but it's evidence
that a problem exists and maybe deserves
further uh investigation
um so finally you know i'm looking at
recruiter relationships and so i can see
that whether recruiter is an intimate
partner that predominantly affects
um victims of sexual exploitation uh who
are female
and the
same applies for family recruiters
but if i look at friends i see that
forced labor is the the most closely
associated
form of trafficking
and within
victims of forced labor we see that
males kind of dominate uh females
so again um these are some of the kinds
of insights that you can generate um
let's look at now for victims of
trafficking who've been trafficked for a
long time five or more years
we can notice that this is a particular
issue for citizens of myanmar
who are exploited in
indonesia and again if we're a policy
maker who is uh involved in any of those
countries this could give us some of
these preliminary guidance about what
kind of thing we should be looking for
that can help us to make progress
against the problem
uh but again all those hypotheses that
we were just discussing you know that
are suggestive that they're not kind of
conclusive um so the next stage is to
you know try to develop evidence of
causation from this observational
data collected
in the real world for some other purpose
so just as a reminder this is the
process we're trying to support and
these are the barriers that we're facing
um the synthetic data showcase tool that
you've just seen um you know it works by
granting access uh by decision makers um
who are not data scientists to be able
to view explore and make sense of
private data for themselves
and the same tool can provide access to
data if your goal is to develop some
evidence of causation but it doesn't
address the issue of how do you make the
data science of causal influence
accessible to decision makers this is a
really hard problem um but thankfully we
had a great um kind of place to start
based on some work that was done by our
partners through microsoft research uh
studies in pandemic preparedness um so
our partners at johns hopkins university
in stanford um wrote a paper on rules
for performing this kind of
retrospective cause of analysis of real
world data in this case it was for
covert drug discovery um but they also
generated this list of guidelines for
how to emulate a randomized controlled
trial uh in the real world um
and this is you know we think an
excellent foundation for building a tool
that makes this process of causal
influence accessible to policy makers
and decision makers
and what's critical about these methods
is that you know domain experts are
domain expertise is critical and it's
conventionally represented as this kind
of graph showing the causal
relationships operating in the domain
but um the problem is people don't tend
to carry these graphs around in their
head they have to be elicited
interactively they take time to to
develop
and this is not something you can
delegate to a data scientist who perhaps
doesn't have domain knowledge so what
can you do
so our response is to build a tool that
we're calling show why so show why
enables the main experts to evaluate
causal questions
over real world data via a guided
process without assuming too much
kind of familiarity or expertise in data
science and a non in causal inference
and it works by emulating randomized
controlled trials to the best extent
possible using observational data
already collected for some other purpose
um show white evaluates many alternative
specifications to show the impact of
decisions and assumptions made along the
way
especially kind of essentially arbitrary
decisions and thresholds that may
potentially have an outsized impact on
the resulting estimates and finally it
encourages interactive presentation of
the developed evidence and uh
reproducible analysis through the
download of interactive reports and code
and things like jupyter notebooks
we call it show why because it's powered
by causal inference uh using do y and
economial two uh uh libraries for course
of inference uh developed by microsoft
so let's dive into a show wide demo now
uh so here's the tool
on the left we can see a structured
workflow that guides the user through
the process of defining a question
acquiring data estimating effect sizes
against that data and
communicating those results so you know
the kind of question that we can answer
here is for population does exposure
cause outcome to
do something hypothesis increase
decrease or change so here's a you know
pre-loaded analysis um on victims of
trafficking and the question is for
identified victims of trafficking does
the experience of a recent natural
disaster in your country of citizenship
as a victim uh caused the severity of
control to increase or cause the the
chance of you experiencing a severe more
means of control to increase and again
the various theories in the domain as to
why this might be the case
um so the tool kind of gets the user to
document their question the data sets
that they might use the reasoning behind
it and all the different ways in which
they might define the different elements
of the question so for instance in terms
of the population um if we're using the
ctdc synthetic data set you know do we
use complete records only or are we
allowed to impute some attribute values
there are two different ways of defining
the people over which will do the
analysis and similarly we can define
different um
levels of exposure in terms of the
degree of uh severity of the disaster uh
maybe also different levels of outcome
these are all alternative framings of
the same kind of high level question
next we ask the user to think about all
the possible factors that might be
causally related to the question and
once they've kind of documented those we
can get them to think
uh one page at a time which of those
might cause the exposure which might be
caused by the exposure and the same for
the outcome and again along the way we
we capture the user's um kind of input
in terms of how strongly they believe
this to be the case and why they believe
this to be the case
once we have all that evidence of
potential cause of relationships with
different degrees of belief we can
construct that kind of causal graph
and we can ask do y on the back end to
evaluate whether or not it's possible to
evaluate the target question given the
causal structure of the domain this is
even before we've looked at any data
based on the different degrees of belief
that we have for whether these causal
relationships exist we can also have
look at different cause of models so for
example this minimum model only includes
age and gender not anything linked to
the countries of citizenship or
exploitation and the unadjusted model is
just looking at the exposure and the
outcome
so uh next um we've defined kind of our
question it's time to to load data and
process the data column by column
indicating whether or not it's causally
relevant to different aspects of the
question or the broader context
and so you know the user is now
systematically going through the
definitions they've created and either
binding to existing columns in their
data sets or using um kind of building
capabilities to derive new columns that
kind of you know move towards the
definition of the thing that they uh
they care about
so we do this for you know population
exposure outcome controls and then we
get to the stage where um we have to
determine how we're going to
statistically estimate the um the effect
size and so you know this is um you know
a real challenge in terms of how we
communicate this it's uh something
that's in its early stages still but you
can see here that you know we're
offering kind of inline guidance about
different
tools and techniques and when and when
they might not be appropriate um and
again because the user is not
necessarily an expert it's best to earn
a side of caution and select multiple
different kinds of estimators
and similarly we have um different kinds
of refutation tests we can use to try to
reject any estimates that you um that
you create based on uh ones that appear
to have some of their assumptions
violated um so this is just an
additional line of defense against uh
invalid estimates
so um you know once we have specified
all these different ways of specifying
the problem we get all the
specifications executed on the back end
in parallel to produce all of these
different estimates all of which have
been refuted multiple times
and this is the result and so what we
can see is a chart where we are ranking
our effect sizes in increasing order uh
effect sizes above zero represent a
positive impact below zero represent a
negative impact um and we can see here
these are these blue dots that i'm
pointing to uh these are from the
unadjusted model we know that's bad so
we can just eliminate those results
and view the remaining points and how
the exclusion of those estimates affects
the mean and median
effect size
next we can see that we have a whole
kind of row of results from the minimum
model that appear to be pushing uh the
effect size downwards uh using machine
learning we can actually uh show that
this is indeed the case and we can argue
that maybe that minimum model wasn't
valid it didn't capture all of our
domain knowledge and so we're not going
to use that for our final
analysis
the estimated selection didn't appear to
make a significant systematic impact uh
either way which is good um
but our definition of exposure did so if
we defined a severe disaster as one of
the top fifty percent over all countries
in all time um we see that that has
downward pressure on the results but
actually we only really care about very
severe disasters because only then do we
really think that this uh phenomenon
would occur so we can eliminate those uh
two forms of exposure and we're left
with um two alternative uh ways of
dividing the population um from records
that were already complete in the source
data versus ones that we completed by
imputation um and this is the the ctdc
synthetic data set and what's nice to
see here is that it doesn't really
matter which one we use
we're getting kind of consistent results
either way
so now we can go through the process of
looking at the remaining estimates one
by one and seeing
how they fared when passed through this
refutation process and any um
results that don't pass kind of all of
the reputations we can just reject and
say okay there's something wrong about
this um somehow we could learn more by
drilling down into the refutation test
that will fail but for now let's just
dismiss them uh and uh and see what kind
of curve we're left with in particular
what the
remaining average causal effect sizes
look like
um so almost uh finished with that
process
this one passed all five
and uh and this one passed all five so
that's great um and so we can see that
you know we're looking at average
effects around uh 0.3 which means that
for identifying victims of trafficking
giving this analysis a recent natural
disaster doesn't appear to increase the
chance of experiencing means of control
by around 30 percent we can go on now to
evaluate the hypothesis kind of formally
or we could
save from this the entire project the
derived data sets uh a report or reduced
a notebook containing the code of the
analysis i'd like to point out this is
not a peer-reviewed
study it's just an illustrative example
of the kinds of question that you can
answer using show y
and so here's a snapshot of the kind of
notebook that you can generate um it's
too long to go through in detail it's
not the kind of thing that a decision
maker
or domain expert would generate but it's
something that you could pass to
somebody who is an expert in data
science or cause of inference to
validate or audit the work that you have
done
okay so today we're talking about
translating raw data into evidence um
this is the process we're trying to
support um it has barriers along the way
and today i've described two tools to
help to overcome those barriers so one
is synthetic data showcase from private
data sharing to the show why based on do
i uh for guided cause of inference and
so i've shown examples in the human
trafficking space but i hope you can
appreciate that these uh tools have very
broad relevance across the mains uh
especially for healthcare and public
health or any issue of public um sorry
of uh health equity
uh so uh synthetically the showcase is
available on github now as is do why
show i will be coming uh to github in
december uh 2020 what and you know these
are not independent tools they're
designed to be complementary that
they're designed to work together and
you know synthetic data showcase can be
used to share data inputs for
retrospective analysis to show why just
as the data outputs from show y can be
passed through synthetic data showcase
to enable a more reproducible auditable
and privacy preserving
kind of analysis and again both of these
kind of considerations uh about creating
a more equitable and collaborative form
of data science and that's just what we
need to solve problems like trafficking
healthcare public health and all the
other challenges of societal resilience
and to learn more about our efforts in
this space please navigate to aka the ms
forward society resilience and select
research
thank you very much